drew brees was a tenth of a percentage
point away from tying his own single
season record for completion percentage
brees actually owns four of the top five
completion percentage seasons in nfl
history
who has the other one wow is this
obvious this one let me give you a hint
yeah it came within the last five years
oh i know
i i mean
he threw a lot of short passes
he threw a lot of short passes
gosh who am i missing here i almost
wanted to say derek carr this year but i
i'm not i don't and i'll go with derek
carr this year
who is it who the hell is it sam
bradford 2016. all right
you're right when you needed five he'd
get you seven when you needed ten he'd
get you seven i forgot all about off
kyle rudolph kyle rudolph somehow
basically
it was a little handoff it was basically
a shovel pass that went beyond the line
of scrimmage it's easy to get 71.6
when you do that i'm surprised it wasn't
higher i wouldn't have guessed that i
totally had forgotten that uh until you
mentioned it obviously all right uh i
get the first pick and you know what i
don't know maybe we're gonna disagree
maybe this isn't the consensus number
one pick but he's the consensus mvp and
i think lamar jackson is gonna play
great in the postseason i and he it's
important for him to play great this
post season because last year he didn't
and that was his first experience in
single elimination football and you
don't want it to become
a narrative you don't want it to become
two rough years in the postseason
remember last year they were one and
done against the chargers in the wild
card round you don't want to have that
barry bonds vibe where hey you can get
it done in the regular season you can't
get it done when it counts it's critical
for lamar jackson and i think the ravens
know that and i think he's going to play
great i think that's been part of his
maturation process this year that no
game is too big no game is too small
every game is the same and we're going
to see that out of him and i think he's
going to be as
as impactful in the postseason as he was
in the regular season and if that's the
case he's going to be the best
quarterback in the playoffs yeah well
yeah i hear you i mean to me it was
between him or than the guy i'm about to
pick but yeah i'm with you i mean one
he's got tremendous talent and two he's
on the best team right that's where i
you know i want to fight back against
this draft a little bit and go well the
quarterbacks i think that are going to
play really good are on the really good
teams too but
patrick patrick hey yeah you get the
text messages you have a chance to give
your input on what the segments are
going to be i don't know what you were
doing last night i don't really get the
input i can show the history of that i
don't really get it i say things like
that you don't provide the input
influence i gave up months ago i've been
vetoed more than i don't know but i've
been vetoed so i just have given up on
that patrick mahomes will be my pick
though okay uh yes i mean patrick
mahomes
it's it's if you gave me one quarterback
to take in all of football right to
build my team around i want patrick
mahomes and i think patrick mahomes
understands taking care of the football
and as far as the drop back pass game
goes there's nobody that's able to
create more with less when a play is not
there or nobody's open or whatever it
may be let alone he does have a good
coach around him and be enemy and air uh
and and andy reid that create you know
good plays for him and of course talent
too so uh i go with patrick mahomes as
my next one where's my yeah that would
have been my second pick as well and
look here's where it gets a little bit
challenging because we have to we have
to predict who's going to not be one and
done who's going to play multiple games
how well will they play in that one game
and you know what i i could i could
play this game with you
because i don't think you're going to
take the guy that i'm about to take but
i don't care because
i still fear the terminator and i even
with the uh my arm it's broken
i still believe that tom brady thrives
on single elimination football and that
that exp he has what how many postseason
games does he play we do this every year
and i always forget he's got like two
seasons of postseason games it's two
seasons right yes right yeah and and he
can slide into that mindset where other
guys may freak out he he relishes it he
loves it and he knows everyone is
possibly going to be his last one and he
that that gives him an even greater
likelihood of playing well so i think
that that brady uh um
to get ready get ready folks i know
you're ready to move on from the
patriots and see somebody else hoist a
trophy um
i'm not ready to say that that's going
to happen
happening this year i'm on the record
right now december 31st
2019 the last day of the decade for
poindexter okay uh
this is i am ready to say the patriots
won't go to the super bowl this year but
either way i understand your pick and
because of kind of the logic you just
talked about you know again i'm going to
pick a guy that i don't think is as good
as a lot of the quarterbacks on this
list
but i'm going to go with drew brees
i am yeah i know it might surprise you
but the saints are one of the best teams
in football sean payton's one of the
best offensive play designers uh there
is in the game
jared cook alvin kamara you know michael
thomas they got weapons cameron meredith
coming on so there's a lot of things at
his disposal do i think he's as talented
as some of the guys we haven't talked
about absolutely not you know i think
there's a lot of quarterbacks we can put
in new orleans and they would have you
know these kind of results too but i
think drew brees is smart he's played
playoff football he's been playing well
lately i think the saints have really
hit their stride as of late and i go
with him
i gotta go with russell wilson next
because of his history of playing well
in the postseason even in games where he
doesn't play well remember the four
interceptions in the first half against
the packers in the nfc championship game
2014 got it together and he's a guy who
appreciates those moments he's got a
nice wealth of history of single
elimination football and you know look
that that relies on the seahawks being
able to beat the eagles on sunday and i
know chris i think both of uh both of us
yesterday are knee jerk initial lean was
the eagles seahawks yeah but but yeah
it's russell russell wilson man yeah
scary can't go to sleep on russell
wilson right reality's starting to set
in and i think i'm i'm my lead changing
already yeah i'm starting i'm starting
to it's about about back to eve yeah
right
from nightmares yeah but i but i think
we've seen enough from russell wilson to
know he's going to play well in the
postseason yeah i i agree i mean russell
wilson yeah it's just about how good he
plays and will they help him out a
little bit really i mean we know he's
gonna play good i'm with you there i
mean russell wilson's phenomenal he's
one of the best in the game all right
again i'm gonna go with i'm going with
jimmy garoppolo you're asking me what
quarterbacks i think will play the best
the next month okay well i'm gonna go
with jimmy garoppolo first off i think
they're gonna win their divisional
playoff game whoever comes to town i
mean as we've seen as of late i mean
garoppolo's stats have been through the
roof not that i'm gonna sit here again
and tell you that he's better than
mahomes or lamar jackson or you know
desean watson who we haven't picked no
he's not as good as them but shanahan's
an awesome game plan designer they run
the ball they got support system and i
think there's a very good chance they
end up in the super bowl so you know i'm
gonna go with jimmy garoppolo i expect
him to kind of continue where he left
off the other night
but can't they win without him playing
at a high level um
maybe in the first round they might get
away with it uh but i don't think
they're gonna be able to win an nfc
championship game or be competitive that
way he's gonna have to play like he did
in the saints game or the other night in
the seahawks game to where yeah i think
he's gonna have to play pretty damn good
if they want to win some of these
well here's what we do is we communicate
back and forth digitally as to what the
topics are what the segments are we have
a grid
of these selections in every draft box
it's got lines it looks nice what i'm
going to do after this show i'm going to
copy it i'm going to paste it i'm going
to print it i'm going to laminate it and
i'm going to send it to green bay
wisconsin i knew you were going to say
that so so that aaron rodgers will see
that
you had three picks it's
but i do it's my version man i'm trying
to put my own spin off okay get off my
case lay off me i'm starving all right
aaron rodgers
excuse me yes uh i i it was painful to
me trust me
i just you know again a little bit like
what we've seen over the last few weeks
you know again devonte adams is a good
receiver he's not a great receiver and
you know i think aaron jones is real
good i don't think he's great and other
than that who else is that who's going
to be that next guy in green bay to help
out you know i think to be a dangerous
offense you have to have legit three
weapons
you know i think if you look at the
really good offenses in the nfl they
they have that rogers doesn't have that
and i just worry about you know i think
he'll play good he understands how to
take care of the football but do i think
his stats and things are going to
measure up to some of the guys we picked
already no i don't and that's kind of
why you know the the packers if they win
they're gonna win ugly with some great
rogers play splashed in there um i guess
the next guy i go make your pick desean
watson deshaun watson you know desean
watson and i know we got no um will
fuller again but yeah i trust desean
watson in these situations i certainly
think they're capable of beating the
buffalo bills this week and if they do
it'll be because he makes some amazing
plays and then oh wow okay they win and
then who knows where they go from there
do they go to you know kansas city or
baltimore we don't know yet um but i
think he'll be dangerous for whoever
he's got to play in that next round
all right i i know there's still a
competitive element to this right we
want to win the draft
but go ahead yeah no but but i'm just i
just want to establish that we're still
trying to win yeah because i'm about to
win the draft you know how i'm going to
win the draft why
taysom hill is my next pick boom you're
done give me taste smell look at my list
and you give me taysom hill and you are
cooked because what do we expect from
taysom hill in the post season more of
what we've seen all year long and we're
going to see more from taysom hill than
we're going to see from some of these
other guys including desean watson and
anybody else you pick in the next two
rounds boom roast did i win what uh i
mean what a just a bs move that was i
mean is he not a quarterback hey does he
not wear number seven he is i mean
you're you're basic yeah uh okay yes
he's a he's technically a quarterback
yes but if he doesn't throw a pass if he
doesn't throw a pound
roasted then oh you'll pass you lose
he'll throw pass okay all right all
right that is some bullcrap pick there
you go next [ __ ] i'm going carson wentz
i'm going carson wentz i think even with
winter loss this weekend the play that
we've seen from carson wentz will
continue he's just on fire he's doing
great things i mean making like
jaw-dropping throws every week they got
nothing around them i go wence
i'm going ryan tannehill yep okay yeah
see you framed this all so you didn't
have to pick kirk cousins that's all it
was all about but i'm taking josh allen
next i am he goes on think about this
yes we picked 12 quarterbacks in a 12
team playoff field and cousins gets
omitted he did well yeah because you're
a jerk and went outside the lines that's
why he got omitted you take you could
take him send you this take him right
now and that little laminated sheet to
curse cousins in minnesota please do i
just crapped on i got a favorite team's
quarterback i got a few other things i'd
like to add to the box josh allen is who
i'm taking okay and i you know i love me
some josh allen um and they can pull
that offset in houston this week
all right well there is our jerk
hey i didn't man hey you uh it started
with
josh or kirk cousins
josh allen okay
all right we gotta go see
uh some more uh comments from jarvis
landry regarding his now former head
coach plus whatever else we cram into
the final few minutes of this tuesday
edition of pft live we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports